we have a David Pakman show subreddit
one of the biggest progressive
subreddits on reddit nearly 10,000 of
our viewers and listeners at david
pakman.com slash our EDD IT regularly
participating in political discussion I
encourage you to join and subscribe
there for free
one interesting post I spotted this
morning is somebody saw me in the
cannabis documentary grass is greener
there is indeed a new Netflix
documentary entitled grass is greener
there is like a three second clip of me
in it right after a very short clip of
our friend from The Young Turks Ana
Kasparian I'm commenting about a black
man who was sentenced to some
extraordinarily long prison sentence
because of draconian drug laws and I got
a bunch of texts from friends including
friends in the marijuana industry saying
David you're in the documentary about an
hour in and I saw it and it's cool I
didn't know I was going to be in it they
did not pay licensing fees which is fine
I just know people sometimes wonder do
we get paid when I appear sometimes yes
sometimes no in this case they didn't
even tell me and that's fine they're
using my clip under fair use I'm not a
hypocrite don't worry I I don't know
anything else about the documentary I
haven't had time to watch it other than
the three seconds I'm in and the
preceding four in which Ana Kasparian
appears but from what my friends have
told me it's a very interesting
documentary so check it out also from
the David Pakman show subreddit a post
from ardell a Vanda or ardella Vanda
saying is it better to bring up and call
out the disingenuous right wing
commentators or hosts or ignore them and
not give them a platform curious what
you guys think people like the
intellectual dark web
tomi Lauren Tommy Lauren I don't know
how she pronounces her name steven
crowder Jesse Lee Peterson is it worth
it or does debunking them or talking
about them give them even more publicity
this is a perfect opportunity for me to
announce I will be having a debate it's
gonna be a conversation I'm gonna be
having a debate we'll still call it with
Steven Bunnell the second also known to
some of you in the gaming world as
Destinee next week it's scheduled for
Tuesday at 6 p.m. Eastern Time
I will be broadcasting it live on our
YouTube channel destiny will be
broadcasting live on Twitch where we are
going to debate platforming and boycotts
to kind of different but related topics
related to censorship and speech and we
are going to debate exactly this when do
you platform someone responsibly how do
you platform people responsibly when
does giving them a platform do more harm
than good by exposing people to their
crazy ideas so we are going to have a
really great conversation live on my
youtube channel and his twitch channel
Tuesday I hope I'm saying this right
Tuesday at 6 p.m. Eastern Time and we
will address it then so I won't address
this question now join the discussion at
david pakman.com slash re d di t today's
sponsor is Skillshare and i'm excited to
tell you that everybody in our audience
is getting two entire months of free
access to Skillshare when you click the
link underneath this video skill shares
the site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at
than 10 bucks a month get better at
whatever it is that you're passionate
about or discover something brand-new
that you didn't even know that you would
love and join skill shares other 7
million users by clicking the link
underneath this video
[Music]